In previous videos, you could see us landscapingaround.
We're taking down trees for good reasons,
mapping the native trees and protecting them.
Allof this to recover the ecosystem,
and make a land more fire resilient in the long run.
But, westill have a lot of work to do...
So, in this video, we are going to improve ourland a little bit more.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
Currently, we are at the top rock area ofthe land.
It's a very rocky underground with several types of vegetation.
Overthere, we have the more dense, mimosa area.
Which, by now, we kind of know how to tacklethat one.
But here, we have a more open space,
with many ferns and native trees in between.
I canexplain you this a bit better,
if we have a look from the top.
To give you some context: here is Basekamp.
Here are the big rocks on the top of the land.
This is the area where we are gonnaclean up,
because it has the most native trees in the whole land.
We want to become a nativeforest!
The reason why we are here on this part of the land
is because next door we have a bigeucalyptus farm from the neighbors.
It's very flammable, that we cannot do anything about!
But, what we cando something about
is how we treat our own land.
For instance: this native tree the cork has been
surviving the fire in 2017, and it's still alive!
This gives us the idea of how strong native treescan be.
So, we want some more of them!
Over there, you can see a madroneo.
This madroneo is now surroundedby mimosas,
but the mimosa is growing two meters a year.
So, in a bit, we don't even see the madroneo anymore...
It will get not get enough sun to grow.
So, this area is mixed with a couple of species.
For example: eucalyptus.
A flammable one,
And then, we haveanother of that: the mimosa.
Both are the same: very flammable, and it's growing very fast too.
So, we want to control them, and see if
the other ones get enough space to grow up strong.
Even after the fire in 2017, the landdidn't get cleared.
So, there is still all the dead wood from burnt trees
laying on topof the native trees that are growing up now.
A lot of dead wood here!
Then, we have these ferns.
They grow very fast, they produce shade,
but is it good or bad?
We don't know yet.
To be figured out!
So, now, we're currently at the bottom part
of the patch that we are going to work on.
It's close to a very dense mimosa patch.
But, we're including this area,
because we still have a lot of native trees growing.
We would loveto include them into the native forest.
Look over here!
Okay, so, that is the work!
It's quite a lot and we are at the height summer,
which means that it's very hot already.
In this space, we almost have no shade.
So,it's quite important to find a healthy way
of working on this area.
Besides that, we also cannot use all of the power tools,
because it's the fire season.
How to approach this?
We don'tknow yet, but luckily,
we are a big team at the moment!
Let meintroduce you to some people!
- Hello! My name is Alon!
I'm 28 years old, andI am currently on a trip across Europe,
in search of a new place to settle and call home.
Asyou can probably already tell, I truly live for danger.
You'll often find me participating in
some extreme sports such as sewing.
A job well done!
Gardening.
And, drawing the occasional masterpiece.
Nature is where I feel my best.
I'd liketo live simply and sustainably in the future.
So, I've come to Project Kamp to learn aboutthis way of living,
and to see the challenges I may face myself.
As well as to help out, wherever I can and gain some new experiences!
- Hello! My name is Doris!
I'm 26 years old, and I'm from the Netherlands!
Iam a painter and also do poetry and spoken words.
I grew up in the middle of a city,
andnature was something I knew as the grassbetween the pavement.
I really love to be in nature for longer periods of time.
That is why I came to Project Kamp!
Livingwith much less comfort and materialistic things
is really inspiring to me!
To really see how creativity flows from that.
- Okay! Enough chit-chat!
Let's get back to work!
- Good morning!
- First, we need some tools:
A brush cutter.
A saw.
Another saw!
A lopper.
- This morning, we got upvery early,
to start really before the heat is there.
We're gonna clear this mimosa part
to create some space for us.
- We divided the whole area in three parts.
This part we called 'Bottom Mimosa'.
Okay! Now it's time to start!
We started by chopping most of the small mimosas,
to access the area with more native trees.
Once we opened the entrance path,
we are able to access thesection and continue working.
Here we start to see the native trees!
- So, it's seven in the morning,
and how are you guysfeeling?
Excited and energised!
- Yay.
Let's go free the oaks!
- As you can see, it's really hard to get aroundhere.
That's also why we are making these paths.
A lot of dead trees fell on the young ones...
- Going out.
As you may be able to see behind me,
weactually found a whole line of smaller oaks.
So, what we're going to do is to free up somespace around them.
This is so they can hopefully grow into a strong native forest.
- Did youguys find a new species?
Yes, we did!
- What is it?
Ale, what is it?
- It's a 'medronheiro', and I think it's called a'strawberry tree',
with some really bright red fruits!
We also had to figure out ways to dealwith the heat.
We found some tricks!
- The sun has come out.
It's getting hot, girls...
- It is!
What's up, water boy?
- Just doing my thing!
The water boy has company.
In order for us to take all the
necessaryprecautions to be fire safe...
We always bring a bucket with us,
in case the brush cuttersmight hit a rock, and ignite a spark.
It is also something that we use to help us
cooldown when it's really hot.
- There's a bunch of oaks around,
so everyonehas kind of gone and picked a oak to clear.
So, I am trying to clear this one.
I think there's another one hidden here behind me,
so hopefully, in halfan hour or so, I have plenty more space.
- Ingrid!
Yes?
- How do you feelabout killing other mimosas?
Conflicted!
I know that people have anissue with the mimosas,
but I only arrived a week ago...
So, I feel like I need a bit more time?
They're beautiful trees as well, so I don't know!
But, I'm glad we can make space for some othertypes!
- How do you feel about killing the mimosas?
I think it'squite hard to do so many at the same time.
But then, I know from last year,
that it's super good for the native trees!
To really get some sunlight, and to get a chance to grow.
There'sso many out here,
so I can also imagine it to be like a big forest again.
So, that's kind ofcool!
- Okay, we only cleared a couple of square meters.
Even though we only clear around thenative trees,
we have a big pile of green matter already.
This one we would say is alreadya bit too high
to leave behind, because of the risk of fire.
What we decided now is tomake smaller piles
and mainly on the water lines.
So, this is one of the examples.
Here is a water line where the water rainwater gets collected,
and runs all the way down.
Tostop this a bit, we would put green matter over here in small piles.
Hopefully, itstops the rain a bit from flowing.
Okay, so, as you might see, we placed all the
branches in the area where the water wouldflow down.
It might not seem a lot, butin the winter all the water will flow,
and it this will hold more water.
So, bit by bit, this will grow andgive things,
like this little oak the space to grow.
- As you can see, we already took out a lot
of the wood that was hanging around in thetrees.
We put it on the ground,
so it helps with quickerdecomposing.
However, there is still this huge pile of wood...
So, we're gonna find waysto use them,
and make the piles a bit smaller.
We can also use it to place them
around the native trees that we cleared.
Just so it retains water,
and so helps also with recoveringthe soil.
We don't take out all the dead wood,
because some of these trees are still attachedto the ground.
They're actually quite some bugs and birds that really like that.
So, thisone is gonna stay!
- Besides keeping the dead wood in the ground,
we want to make an upgradefor the bugs.
So, we are making a bug hotel!
We are going to use all of these different
materials as VIP-rooms that bugs like to go into.
So, this is our new bug hotel!
- We are very proud to present the grand opening
of Project Kamp's first bug hotel!
I knew this would happen!
Yeah!
- Okay, enough work fortoday.
This day is finished.
- Okay, so, at this point, we'vecompleted cutting down
the first section of this forest.
We've cut down a lot of the mimosas,
and created space for ourselves to move around.
At this point, we have to cut our way upto the big rock.
This is where things become a little bit more
treacherous as there is less shade...
So, it's a lot hotter!
Plus, we'll be working a lot around the tojo,
which is this very spiky, brambly bush.
It can be quite painful to work with,
but we should do quite fine!
- So, for this second area, we called it 'Middle Tojo'.
Let's start!
- Good morning!
We look like NPC's!
- In the summer in Portugal, it is really onlyallowed
to use power tools in the mornings, as there is less fire risk.
So, today, it's a perfect cloudy and cool morning for us
to bring out the power tools.
To continue to free some of the native plants.
- Alon, how do you feel about the spiky stuff?
It'slike these spikes are made out of spikes...
- How do your legs feel?
My legs are in pain!
- They are and they have swollen,
butit goes down after a nice cold shower!
Yeah, they do.
- Great protection...
They can grow very big sometimes!
- So, the tojo is really difficult towork with!
However, we discovered that it's actually a great sign
in the first stepof regenerating a forest.
So, the prickly tojo creates protection for the native trees.
It allows them to grow!
Eventually, as the natives grow and create more shade,
thetojo naturally dies down again.
So, we've cut some of the tojo around the native trees,
to clear up a bit more space.
What we can do now is we can replace the cut tojo
around the base to strengthen the soil.
- Up there is the big rock,
which is what we're trying to reach.
And, on our way there, we're essentially creating
pathways through thebrambles.
Basically, creating clearings around all of the native trees,
so that they have the spaceto grow and flourish.
- Let's go!
Let's do it!
- After making the path, we unlocked a new area!
So, now we will start to work
on the most rocky point of the land.
We called it'the Top Rock'.
On the map, it's right here.
Okay! So, here is another oak.
It's time to free it!
Okay, so, as you can see, we not have only a oak,
but also some little pines!
There is another oak around the corner.
All freedup and ready to grow!
- I didn't expect a helmet.
We'll wear it for YouTube.
- We are almost at the top now
Right there, wehave the land of the neighbors.
Over there, maybe in the distance, you can see the two bigrocks.
Here, there's still a lot of dead wood lying around
from all the dead trees.
So, today,we're gonna clear that.
Do you feel ready?
- Most certainly!
Again, we collected the dead wood in piles.
- Otis, do you like being in the General Help team?
It's going really well!
- That was so cool!
I know.
- I managed to clear around the trees!
There are abunch of branches that were on the floor
that the ferns had completely covered.
So, hopefully, theywill have now more space,
and can grow upwards.
There's actually a couple of oaks,
and they have completely intertwined!
They seem to almost be growing out of the rock.
So, in the middle of a cluster of young oaks, you'll often find
an old dead wood from the fire fiveyears ago.
All the new trees branch out fromunderneath and can grow.
We're still a little bit unsure, whether to keep them standing
or to take them down.
If we leave them standing, it is still a bit of a hazard...
Theyhave a chance of falling over!
So, in some cases, we're removing them.
I'm going to see howthat goes, and other ones we're leaving up.
- Oh! What did you find?
I found a vertebrae of an animal.
- Which animal?
I don'tknow, but it must have been quite big, I'd say!
- We also found a lot of these clay pots here,
which were used to collect resin from the pine trees.
Guys! Four more minutes of brush cutting!
- Do a little dance! Yeah!
So, the clearing of the third section is done.
For now, enough change has been made.
We opened up a lot of space for the native trees.
Withall of these paths around, it would be nice to have some signs
to teach each others about this area.
- We're gonna make some signs for the native trees.
We're gonna put the names on wooden plates,
sowe can give some information about other nativetrees we found.
- What are we going to use for that?
Leftover wood!
We collected some stones now, and now we're gonna crumble it
with this hammer to make it into smaller pieces.
We're gonna add some linseedoil into the pigment.
I use linseed oil, because it's a quick drying oil.
So, when it meets the oxygen,
it will go from a liquid to a hard permanent coating.
It should be very durable!
My first study!
We can fix it!
- We can fixit.
Okay, so the work is done!
Let me show you what we did.
We cleared around the native trees for example.
Around a meter!
This oak for example was only visible from the top.
It was fully covered by tojo.
We cleared allthe tojo around,
and now we have space to grow!
We did the same with this tree.
This tree also!
Two more trees here!
Another one over here!
And, another one over here!
Besides these, manymore in this patch.
So, you might see some changes,
but they're not very noticeable yet.
The realbig change will only appear in the long run,
when all these young trees are growing big intoa nice forest.
Until that happens, they first need still a bit of shade.
This is why we leftsome mimosas up,
and we took the small ones down.
We also created some pathways in the area,
to access the spaces more easily.
This for the maintenance in the future,
but alsoto live a bit more in the area.
Because, when you spend time in the place, it stays way nicer!
A nice roundabout!
So, for the future forest, we alreadyplaced in some signs.
These will identify the trees.
For example, this Cav arlhoSobreiro, but also many others, like...
So, remember the castanedo in the beginning?
Allsuper clean!
We placed all the dead wood around,
so the bugs still have a place to stay.
But,they also got a city upgrade which is a hotel!
So, with all the green matter and the dead wood
that came from the area...
We created some water retention lines
This is to help the soil becomemore furtile,
and to not let everything run off.
So, here are some nice stairs for the accessto the path.
Some more water retention lines.
To give you an idea of the scale of this project,
we worked with around a group of seven to eightpeople.
For around five weeks, and we spent like 400 hours
on the land, so we did only the mornings.
With a lot of extra scratches, a lotof team building,
and understanding howto use the tools in such a big space...
We did a great job!
Okay! That was it for this video!
The next video is going to be about the pig trailer.
You can support us on Patreon, and you can see it without ads!
Or, you wait one week, and see it on YouTube.
Thank you for watching!